All right, here's a big one.
Finish the SynchAdapter,
making it fetch the weather
and store it in the database.
Alter the updateWeather function
within the ForecastFragment
to start a sync with the SyncAdapter.
Some hints here.
Pull the code from
on handle intent into our SyncAdapter.
On handle intent is inside
of our Sunshine service.
The good news is that abstract threaded
sync adapter provides a background thread
to run the server fetch on,
just like intent service does.
Also, just fetch the location
query from our utility class.
Eventually, we want to run syncs
like this without
any involvement of the user.
Finally, make the sync adaptor run
when we call Update Weather.